hello everyone Karen Gordon with film
courage the radio show were outside the
studio with Jeannie Villette Bowerman
and Douglas a Blackman and together
they're adapting Douglass's 2009
Pulitzer prize-winning book slavery by
another name they're collaborating
together on a screenplay and we talked
about several things about how the two
of you met were curious what you're
doing in LA what did we first came up
for great American pitchfest we did that
last year and pitched the script there
for the first time and this time we came
back to speak yesterday we do a speaking
engagement on a case study of how we
adapted the book and also tried to span
it into regular adaptations as novels
and could make it relatable to the
audience members to teach them something
about how they could on to do the same
thing so that was really fun we did as a
favor to the founders of the great
American pitch fest because they're you
know personal friends of mine I really
love them I think that the event is
wonderful for screenwriters to have
access to producers and agents and
managers who they couldn't normally
access and they're all pitching there
today and in reality the main reason
we're is to be on film courage yes the
whole trip was about that we've got
someone the meetings over the next few
days with some actors and producers
trying to find the right combination of
people to try to make the film happen
okay now in addition to what you're
working on I understand that PBS is also
hoping to do a documentary slated for
release in 2012 so how did that come
about did PBS contact you or did you
contact PBS the documentary film grew
out of that after the book came out I
was approached by three or four
different production companies that were
the idea of a documentary film based on
the book before the Pulitzer and and
there were two main sort of teams who
were interested in getting the rights to
the book for that one of which was it
was sort of the main figure and one team
was Sam Pollard who's a great
african-american legendary really
african-american documentarian filmmaker
a great collaborator of Spike Lee on
many of his most important work and
including the Oscar nominated for two
little girls documentary and also have
eyes on the prize and hold dozens of
other amazing important films and so
there was a team that involves him and
then there was not a production team
that was the the national productions
arm of Minnesota Public Television TPT
Productions which is one of the big
producers of of high quality content for
PBS and so the two of them were both
seeking rights to make a documentary and
fortunately in the end well not so
fortunately so I was faced with this
dilemma between one team that really had
the resources and the infrastructure and
the the ability to make a film very
obvious that being the TPT productions
in Minnesota and then another group that
had a kind of artistic vision for the
film that was incredibly compelling and
so I was really at a dilemma of which of
those to go with ultimately I did a deal
with TPT Productions but we immediately
turned around and hired Sam Pollard as
the director of the film and so I ended
up with the kind of dream team
of the right people both in terms of the
infrastructure of how to make the film
and then the most creative most artistic
kind of talent that we could possibly
bring to a project like this so that's
how and they were doing talking to them
where I'm about at the same time and I
approached you right yeah and it took a
long time you know it's a good long long
time to figure out what was the best way
to go and I've talked with all those
parties for over a long period of time
but then we went into production about a
year ago began shooting and are written
initially raising the money which we've
done for the most part that we still
trying to raise a little one and but the
principal photography ended about a
month ago and there'll be a rough kind
of the documentary finished sometime
this month and one of the meetings out
here this week is to try to nail down
narrator the film hopefully very
identifiable from an african-american
actor and and so it should be should be
on PBS sometime this year and maybe have
a limited theatrical release this one
that's what we have so how is the
documentary impacted the screenplay that
you're working on well I think you know
what I was saying that I'd approached
him at the same time that he started
talking to the documentary company
companies but was really serendipitous
about that was it gave Doug the
opportunity to still have some sense of
control over what we were doing and what
the documentary was doing so that the
projects wouldn't wouldn't overlap that
they would complement each other in
terms of educating people and
entertaining people but that they
wouldn't be overlapping and similar
projects so that really helped us with
our project it's just you know for that
whole continuity of it and be sure we
were really covering all the angles
so I I loved having the documentary as
part of it you know sort of the least
some of the pressure for me to make this
educational you know we could sort of
skip all that exposition and know that
that was going to be covered in the
documentary version if people want to
learn more they can go watch the
documentary and vice versa you know so I
I think the book projects really
complement each other well yeah and that
was a very important thing to me from
the very beginning that that if I did
sell rights to do a documentary or a
feature film that did not exclude the
other because I always had the feeling
that there was a real opportunity for
both kinds of films to be done
ultimately and the documentary was the
logical first project to get underway
because it does cover the historical
landscape and and they are very
different films and it did release us to
to write a screenplay that is really is
a film film it is based on real events
and real characters but it is also
definitely a different story different
kind of story and it doesn't have the
same burden of the history lesson
exactly though it illuminates a period
of time in a period of history that that
is very important and that not many of
us understand very well now interesting
they're coming back to Los Angeles
that's right I'll be back in LA on June
28th for the library park Book Festival
which I appeared there a year ago and
I'll be back this year with a bunch of
other fantastic authors and that event
this year is actually co-hosted by
Bernardo Shirley Kinsey who are
relatives of one of the key characters
in my book and an amazing philanthropist
community leaders in Los Angeles so come
out and see me at the Book Festival